des queues interminables à l'entrée des
rayons bondés
depuis le début de la semaine les
magasins d'alimentation de beyrouth sont
pris d'assaut
plus de 1700 morts ces derniers jours le
qu'ovide n'en finit plus de progresser
au libre en une semaine
trente mille nouveaux cas ont été
détectés dans un pays de six millions
d'habitants un chiffre qui en proportion
équivaut à 300 milles contamination
hebdomadaire dans un pays comme la
france les autorités libanaises ne cache
pas que la situation est préoccupante
le président de la république a évoqué
la gravité de la situation sanitaire
résultant de la propagation de la
pandémie de coronavirus les hôpitaux ne
sont plus en mesure de recevoir des cas
et nous avons vu des scènes tragiques
impliquant des citoyens attendant devant
les hôpitaux à la recherche d'un lit
face à la saturation des hôpitaux les
autorités ont décrété lundi l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et un bouclage total
du pays
il est interdit de sortir dans la rue et
sur les routes entre 5 heures du matin
le jeudi 14 janvier 2021 et 5 heures du
matin le lundi 25 janvier des mesures
drastiques en vigueur pendant 11 jours
et qui font souffler un vent de panique
sur la population
tout le monde veut faire des provisions
surtout ceux qui ont des enfants je
m'inquiète de ce que je peux trouver
pour mes enfants avant de penser à moi
le pays sera entièrement bouclé pas le
droit d'aller faire ses courses de
l'exercice ou de promener son chien
les frontières terrestres et maritimes
seront également fermés à tous les
voyageurs sauf à disposer d'un visa
haddock
ces mesures s'ajoutent à un contexte
déjà difficile dans le pays du cèdre
beaucoup de secteurs s'effondre
économiquement ceux qui ne meurent pas
du coronavirus meurent de faim ceux qui
ne peuvent pas télétravail est par
exemple vont perdre leur salaire en
restant chez eux
je peux me permettre de rester à la
maison pendant dix jours
mais il ya des gens qui vont mourir de
faim s'ils doivent rester à la maison
pendant dix jours les hôpitaux privés
représentent au liban plus de 80% du
secteur hospitalier
contrainte d'augmenter la capacité de
leur unité de soins intensifs
ces structures sont toujours dans
l'attenté du paiement d'arriérés par
l'état conséquence certains
établissements resigne parfois
accueillir des patients atteints du coc
vite 19 avec une hausse de 70% des
contaminations par rapport à la semaine
précédente
le liban fait partie des pays
connaissant l'une des plus fortes
progressions dans le monde derrière le
portugal le nigeria ou encore l'irlande
le pays doit recevoir en février sa
première livraison du vaccin father
biotech